[Music]
thank you
what are you doing
until
my middle eyes
tell Basim the story of the feather
our tradition of the feather comes from
Egypt
the feathers of the Heron were dipped in
the blood of the targets
the feathers Forge our paths remind us
of who we are
who we can be
the order has held dominion over men and
their Empires for centuries
strike quickly and endlessly
swallow your questions serve without
complaint who is she to tell you when to
strike
everything you do serves the hidden ones
that is a strange kind of freedom
you are not the first to walk the
Shadows broken pour your pain into the
Brotherhood
we are messengers of Justice
and not the final judges
he knows not what he needs
[Music]
have you not wondered that's your nature
foreign
[Music]